well it's better than son of Batman
Justice League throne of Atlantis I
can't exactly say I was excited to go
into this thing because the track record
for the DC animated movies so far based
off the new 52 their whole new
continuity that they're building not
been great we had Justice League war
which was very uneven start and then it
immediately took a nosedive with son of
Batman which was terrible but let's
start positive on this thing most of the
stuff that worked in Justice League war
still works here primarily the action
the action is very well staged it is
fairly regularly paced it's a little bit
bloodier than I think it needs to be and
it feels a bit more gratuitous this time
than it did in Justice League war not
quite as bad as son of Batman was but it
seems unnecessary like when I see one of
the superheroes take down an enemy I'm
fine with them just punching the guy and
he drops I don't need him to be cut in
half and blood spray everywhere maybe I
just grew out of that I don't know but
the actress still pretty good although I
can't give this movie quite the same
pass on that basis that I gave to
Justice League war because while the
action is good I don't like that this
appears to very clearly be an action
franchise now I mean the older DC
animated movies they always had action
but I never would have described them as
action movies with a one or two
exceptions for the most part you just
wouldn't love them as that you wouldn't
sell them to somebody as it's an action
movie these that's kind of what they are
is kind of what they've all been and I'm
not loving that as a general trend but
again the action is good
there's no sore spots on the voice cast
this time and then there were some
pretty big ones when we dealt with son
of Batman so that's a nice improvement
again Bob out on par with what we got
with Justice League Wars now they've
have won fairly big improvement which is
Wonder Woman because in Justice League
war she was so bad I use grinding my
teeth every time she was on thankfully
that's been largely corrected because
first of all they recast I feel a little
bit bad because I think Michelle
Monaghan's delivery in Justice League
war was probably the fault of the
writers and the director they didn't
replace her with rosario Dawson who
gives a bit more of that stoic strength
that I like and expect from Wonder Woman
which is also an indicated that they're
now writing her properly as opposed to
the ridiculous stupid fish-out-of-water
jokes they were using her for in Justice
League war so massive improvement for
her
there was another casting replacement
they recast the voice for Green Lantern
now it's now Nathan Fillion which is not
a bad thing I'd like Nathan Fillion I
like him as Green Lantern the thing is
though there was nothing wrong with the
guy who they had doing Green Lantern in
Justice League war you know they fix
something that wasn't broken so that
that struck me as a little odd most of
the new blood is pretty soft and really
the big focus here is on Arthur curry
aka Aquaman this is at the heart of it
his story and his stories handled fairly
well for the most part
unfortunately this really would have
been a much better movie if it wasn't a
Justice League movie because the two
don't really cross paths for a while I
mean the Justice League is kind of aware
that there's something going on under
the sea and they're looking into that
and Arthur curry is dealing with his own
personal issues and sort of coming to a
realization of who he is and how he's
torn between two worlds the Justice
League factors and very peripherally to
that and then the thing as it hit its
climax really started to fall apart I'll
come back to that in a bit if they're
gonna remain so rigid to this 75 minute
runtime they really needed to drop the
rest of the Justice League out of this
and just make it an Aquaman movie I feel
like we could have gotten a better depth
and better impact out of Aquaman's side
of the story because there's a lot of
stuff in there that feels like there's a
lot more to this story than you're
giving us particularly in terms of
Atlantis and the backstory of the royal
family that's already in place Aquaman's
mother and his half-brother and there's
a struggle going there you feel that
there's history but the movie does not
have the time to delve in in anything
more than a surface level where this
really falls down is in orem who is the
primary villain he's just incredibly
one-dimensional now he should be a
pretty deep villain because you think
about it he has lived in Atlanta sees
pure Atlantean he has a right to the
throne but his mother she would rather
have his half-brother who has never even
lived in Atlantis and knows nothing
about it take the throne rather than him
I mean that's a legitimate gripe for
somebody to have he's like you're gonna
bring in this guy who you didn't raise
you know virtually nothing about you're
gonna let him sit on the throne whether
I've lived with these people and I know
this world there's real drama to be
mined from that but they make him so
over-the-top evil and they just push it
too far then it just it doesn't have the
impact that the setup could have really
brought and I also need to point out
because I mentioned that really the
climax is where things start to fall
apart and where the film pretty much
lost me completely was as we went into
the final climactic fight now I'll put a
spoiler warning up on this but I don't
think I'm ruining any surprises I mean
that of course it ends in a big fight
they all end in big fights firstly or
himself is really dumb but he's got to
be the worst military tactician in the
history of ever because the way that he
begins his assault on the surface world
is with a massive tidal wave and the
Justice League sees this thing coming
and they know it's gonna hit all up and
down the East Coast primarily the focus
on metropolis naturally so this thing is
approaching metropolis and they say flat
out we can't stop that they're not gonna
be able to save everybody and the title
wave comes up to the city and stops it
stops dead parts like a curtain and
there's arms army why would you have a
title wave come up just to hide your
army and not have the title way to
actually hit the city and do a bunch of
damage that's like dropping a bomb but
when the bomb lands it doesn't explode
it opens up and there's your fighting
squad and they just come out and you
know what coming back to the violence
the film really causes a problem for
itself when it comes to the climactic
battle because you know when they take
on the Atlantean army they are killing
them left and right now that kind of
eases off about midway through the
battle and I figured out why at the end
because Arthur is going to take down arm
and he is going to assume command and he
is now the ruler of Atlantis and
suddenly you know these aren't the
enemies anymore these are our allies but
you shoot yourself in the foot doing
that when only about 10 minutes ago we
were watching them get killed left and
right but suddenly you can't help but go
how many people who thought they were
fighting to defend their
nation did our heroes just slaughter man
this reviews gotten weird on me because
I started off saying it was not that
patent now I've spent so much time
ripping into it look it's not great I'm
certainly not gonna say is great I
hesitate honestly to even say that it's
good it is better than son of Batman son
of Batman just aggravated me from
beginning to end this one started out
fine started out okay but it then it
just went downhill and it never
recovered but it just it makes me not
excited for the movies that are in this
continuity never at this point the only
stuff I'm gonna be looking forward to
anymore is the stuff that is separate
from this continuity like assault on
Arkham was so yes I'm just gonna throw
my feelers out there I personally feel
that the caliber of films that have been
coming out this new continuity based on
the new 52 is just as a whole several
notches down from pretty much the entire
lineup of films that were being done
prior the more standalone stuff do you
think that's the case do you think it's
about the same or do you think that
these are actually better than what we
used to be getting whatever it is drop
something on comets and let's talk about
it as for me I'll be back as soon as I
can get my next fix